pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre delval géopolitologue auteur
de l'ouvragé le projet la stratégie de
conquête d'infiltration à des frères
musulmans en france et dans le monde aux
éditions du toucan
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
d'abord cette passe d'armes entre
emmanuel macron est un homme
politique turque ça veut dire quoi
concrètement que là on est dans des
tensions entre paris et ankara
oui on est des tensions entre paris et
ankara tout à fait logique d'ailleurs la
turquie depuis des années et c'est de
prendre contrôle de l'islam de france un
moment un citoyen d'origine turque était
le président du cfcm
parallèlement les tueurs se sont
beaucoup rapprochés des frères musulmans
et dans le cadre de cette alliance
l'idée c'était même de prendre le
contrôle de pas uniquement des
communautés turques qui sont quand même
des puissances électorale extérieur très
utile pour rire de gamme savait que les
turcs à l'étranger votent plus
erdogan que les turcs en turquie donc
c'est quand même puissance électorale
importante et dans dans ce contexte air
de gan essayer de distiller un sentiment
communautariste turquie islamiste en
même temps qu'ils étaient de plus en
plus en conflit avec les valeurs de la
france notamment les enseignements dans
les écoles dirigées par des turcs en
france on apprend que le génocide
arménien n'a pas existé
on apprend des ddd vision du monde de
l'histoire très nationalistes turcs
révisionnistes et vous savez qu'il ya
une loi en france qui reconnaît le
génocide arménien donc un moment
l'enseignement turque en france étaient
été carrément hostiles aux valeurs et
aux lois et constant à jeddah et perdon
il est issu de la kpc ça cette mouvance
islamiste que l'on dit modéré de moins
en moins enfin est-ce que c'est
compatible avec l'islam politique
non en fait aujourd'hui monsieur erdogan
a repris en main l'état turc depuis une
quinzaine d'années et avant les mosquées
dirigé par l'état turc par le par le
ministère turc de la religion était
relativement proche d'un islam laïc
parce que la turquie était laïc mais
depuis que erdogan a repris en main son
pays est bien le réseau des mosquées
turques géré par l'état turc sont
devenus de tendance islamiste et elle
travaille de concert avec le milli gorus
et d'autres organisations islamistes
radicales turc si vous voulez il ya une
radicalisation de l'islam turc à
l'étranger pas uniquement en france en
allemagne dans toute l'europe parce que
erdogan tient à ce que les turcs ne
s'intègrent pas il a dit que
l'intégration était un crime contre
l'humanité donc aujourd'hui on peut
vraiment dire que erdogan ouvertement
incite à une séparatisme islamistes et
on peut comprendre que mc ren
dénoncer ce séparatisme ce qui n'est pas
normal qu'en france on distille une
vision révisionnistes qui nient le
génocide arménien qui incite le turc à
ne pas s'intégrer et à être de plus en
plus islamiste
je pense que la réaction turque est
logique c'était normal qu'ils réagissent
comme ça en traitant est ce qu emmanuel
macron à un terrain justement à se
mettre à dos la turquie dans le contexte
géopolitique actuel surtout dans la
région la syrie par exemple en fait
c'est un gars pas intérêt à se mettre à
dos la turquie mais il était obligé un
moment de freiner cet opéra de la
turquie sur l'islam français qui est
absolument scandaleuse
d'autant plus que la turquie qui dénonce
le fait que nous on veut intégrer les
turcs en en turquie il ya une
persécution des minorités les alevis
comme l'a très bien dit le président
français les alevis ses 15 millions de
personnes
ils n'ont même pas le droit de pratiquer
leur religion dans les écoles on leur
apprend on les oblige à apprendre les
manuels scolaires sunnite
il faut savoir que les arméniens sont
persécutés aussi en turquie
le responsable de la communauté
arménienne hrant dink a été assassiné
d'autres balles dans la tête il ya
quelques années à istanbul
il a vraiment une persécution des
minorités chrétiennes mais aussi à lévis
en turquie et c'est cet état qui nient
le génocide arménien qui se permet de
traiter la france de raciste et
récemment ce monsieur dans ce
responsable turc a dit que la france
avait fait des massacres enfin c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire de la
part du pays qui a inauguré le génocide
hitler disait lui-même un il prenait le
génocide arménien comme exemple hitler
en disant ce qu'ont fait les turcs pour
pouvoir le faire en allemagne quand on
pense que ce pays négationniste rete la
france de raciste et de et avec une
islamophobie d'état eu ni flamme ni
islamophobie primitive c'est assez
rigolo de la part d'un pays qui
persécutent les orthodoxes vous savez
que les orthodoxes les prêtres
orthodoxes grecs en turquie n'ont plus
le droit de former leurs prêtres depuis
une trentaine d'années le lieu où on
forme les prêtres en turquie les prêtres
orthodoxes a été fermée depuis trente
ans il n'a jamais été ouvert il ya une
persécution de christianisme en turquie
et ce pays se permet de critiquer la
france était donné
accessibilité la réponse la réponse
turque elle est aussi légitime non
macron la réponse turc n'est pas
légitime
elle est logique d'un point parce que en
quelque sorte la turquie est vexé parce
que on a on a en fait démasquer un
véritable progrès sur la sienne un
projet s'est pas ratée lexandre
d'élevage sur la syrie j'aurais vous
entendrez également puisqu'il ya des
combats très violents depuis le début du
mois de février entre les forces de
damas les forces turques alors qu'iliad
ait un accord qui a été conclu avec
moscou entre ankara et moscou pour
justement apaisé dans la région d'idlib
c'est le dernier best le dernier fief
des jihadistes
pourquoi est-ce que c'est difficile de
dénouer ces tensions entre ankara et
damas
attention aussi diplomatiques entre
ankara et moscou alors c'est très
difficile parce que dans le cadre de ces
accords entre iran turquie et russie la
turquie était en charge de l'ouest de
l'euphrate d'une partie dans l'ouest de
l'euphrate où elle devait superviser le
reste des rebelles islamistes et
normalement elle devait mettre fin au
mouvement rebelle lié à al-qaïda ou à
daher et c'est ce qu'elle n'a pas fait
la turquie n'a absolument pas apaisé le
terrain est la même en sous-main
continuer à aider des mouvements
islamistes radicaux qu'elle essaie de
faire maintenant exfiltré vers la libye
pour déstabiliser l'ouest de la libye
contre le général akhtar et c'est pour
ça que la turquie on veut à la france
aussi parce que la france est du côté de
la star tandis que la turquie en libye
et du côté des ennemis de la star y ait
un lien entre la syrie et la libye mais
ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que
la turquie partout l aide des mouvements
islamistes radicaux qui massacre des
arméniens dans le nord de la syrie qui
massacrent aussi d'aider des kurdes on a
des images absolument forcément ce qui
est dit et c'est normal non seulement
vous savez ce qu'il veut faire il veut
prendre toute la méditerranée pour des
raisons pétrolière et gazière
il n'est pas content que le partage des
eaux territoriales ne lui sont pas
favorables et il essaie de faire des
accords avec des mouvements rebelles ou
des gouvernements comme l'ouest de la
libye pour essayer de récupérer une
partie du gaz offshore auquel il n'a pas
droit parce que la géographie elle est
comme elle est et les limites
territoriales
il aimerait en fait rétablir l'empiré
ottoman et il justifie une mainmise sur
le gaz et le pétrole des pays en
méditerranée au nom d'une sorte de
défense des musulmans des islamistes et
des minorités turques parce que ils
jouent beaucoup sur les minorités
turques en syrie en libye
il y à des populations d'origine turque
il s'appuie sur elle pour un
expansionnisme néo ottoman extrêmement
dangereux aujourd'hui la turquie est
probablement le pays musulman le plus
dangereux en méditerranée qui
déstabilise toute la méditerranée et qui
d'ailleurs dérange
la plupart des pays musulmans la plupart
des pays musulmans arabes aujourd'hui
sont victimes d'un d'impérialisme turc
extrêmement arrogant qui veut prendre
des bouts de territoire
erdogan aimerait avoir un bout d'irak un
bout de syrie est maintenant un bout de
libye où il a retrouvé à misrata
chez les milices islamistes des
descendants de turc à qui il propose de
faire une sorte d'extra territorialité
c'est extrêmement dangereux ça rappelle
hitler c'est la politique des minorités
au nom de laquelle en étant un empire en
fait et redonnerait un parallèle même le
poing levé titre et là dessus il a
vraiment une politique expansionniste
fondée sur une vision suprémacistes de
la turquie et néo ottomane c'est-à-dire
néo impérialistes qui inquiète la syrie
le liban l'irak la libye la tunisie tous
les pays arabes sont remercie alexandre
delval je rappelle que vous êtes
géopolitologue et puis auteur de cet
ouvrage
le projet la stratégie de conquête
d'infiltration des frères musulmans en
france et dans le monde aux éditions du
toucan merci à vous remercier